In the previous examples we looked
at systems of equations that had
a unique solution.
However, as we've seen,
it's not always the case that there
is a unique solution to every system.
We need the Gaussian elimination
procedure to be robust against these
cases.
Let's look at the following system.
x + 2y + 3z = 1, 3x + 2y +
z = 0, 7x + 6y + 5z = 2.
We can start solving
the system as usual,
clearing the terms
beneath the top x term.
Subtract three times the first equation
from the second to get -4y- 8z = -3.
And then subtract seven
times the first equation
from the third, to get -8y- 16z = -5.
Then we drop down to
the second equation and
start to clear the y terms beneath -4y.
Subtract two times the second
equation from the third, and
now we're in a very
interesting situation.
There is nothing remaining on the left
hand side of the third equation, but
there is a one remaining on the right
hand side, giving us the equation 0 = 1.
What does this mean?
Well, the original system of equations
assumes that there are numbers x,
y, and z,
which satisfy the three simultaneously.
Since we used legal operations
on the original system and
obtained a false statement, it means
that these supposed numbers x, y,
and z, which satisfy the system,
must not exist.
In other words, this contradiction tells
us that the system is inconsistent.
It has no solutions.
In fact, if we ever run into the case
that the left hand side of an equation
is zero and the right hand side is
not zero, we can immediately stop and
say that the system has no solutions.
This is a nice criterion for
finding systems with no solutions.
But what about systems with
more than one solution?
This is a bit trickier.
Let's modify the system from
before just a little bit,
making the constant term in the third
equation one instead of two.
Again, we start by subtracting three
times the first equation from the second
and continue by subtracting seven times
the first equation from the third.
The third equation now reads,
-8y- 16z = -6.
Now as before, subtract two times
the second equation from the third,
unlike last time, the bottom
equation is not a contradiction.
Certainly zero equals zero.
So what are we to make of this?
Well since zero always equal zero,
regardless of what X, Y, and
Z are,
the last equation becomes redundant.
The system would have the exact same
solution if we dropped it all together.
This is how to interpret an equation
of the form zero equals zero,
the row it occupies was
originally a redundant equation.
It gives no extra information
about the solutions that was
not contained in the equations above it.
In fact, notice that in the original
system, if we added the first equation
to two times the second equation,
we would get the third equation.
So what do we do now?
The system essentially has
only two planes in it,
meaning that the solution
cannot be a single point,
since the planes aren't parallel, the
solution is that will be a line in fact.
Is there anything else we can do?
Yes, like we did with lines earlier,
we can parameterize the solution set,
in other words, we can describe
all the points in the solution set as
a function of some number of parameters.
How can we do this?
First after dropping the zero
equals zero equation,
notice that we cannot clear
terms downward anymore.
Instead what we will do is identify
what are called pivot variables.
These are variables whose values will
be determined by the values of the non
pivot or free variables.
The pivot variables are the variables
which are leading terms in our equations
in this case X and Y are leading terms.
So they are the pivot variables.
Since Z is not a leading term
in any of the equations,
it will be a free variable.
Since Z is a free variable,
it will become a parameter in our
parametrization of the solution set.
Now let's continue our Gaussian
elimination algorithm.
So we can end up with the
parametrization of the solution set of
our system.
In the second equation.
In order to make the pivot variable
have a coefficient equal one,
multiply through by negative one fourth.
The equation now reads y + 2z = 3/4.
Then like we normally do
in Gaussian elimination,
we will clear the terms
above the leading y term.
So we subtract two times the second
equation from the first.
This gives us x- z = -1/2
in the first equation.
Since the leading coefficient
of each equation is now one and
the leading variables only
appear in one equation each,
we have simplified the system
as much as possible.
This form is called reduced
row-echelon form, or rref for short.
We can now parametrize the solution
set in the following way.
Suppose xyz is a point in
the solution set, then x
will have to equal -1/2+z by
rearranging this top equation.
Similarly, by rearranging
the second equation we see that
y has to equal 3/4- 2z.
Finally since z is a free variable,
we set it equal to itself.
This means that for every real value of
z, this point is in the solution set.
Another way we can write this is
to split the vector into a sum
of a constant vector and
a vector with a z term.
This form should be familiar.
It is how we parameterized
the line previously,
except now we're using z instead
of t for the parameter name.
The base point of this
parameterization is negative one-half,
three-fourths, zero, and the direction
vector of this parameterization is one,
negative two, one.
Here are some different points
that are in the solution set
that we can generate by
picking different values of z.
Picking z=0 gives us the basepoint.
Regardless of the value of z
that is picked, we can check
that the point will be a solution to
the original system of equations.